lo que quiero hacer en este vídeo es
mostrarte que algunas de las cosas que
hemos venido hablando en los vídeos
pasados si suceden en particular como
uno de estos casos de ataques
especulativos pueden convertirse en una
crisis bancaria aquí tenemos una gráfica
de oxford economics es una gráfica de
dos cosas la tasa de cambio y la tasa de
interés a corto plazo para tailandia
desde inicio de los noventas hasta el
presente y hay varias cosas interesantes
que tú podrás ver por aquí la primera es
la tasa de cambio puedes observar que
desde inicios de los noventas hasta
finales de los noventas la tasa de
cambio estaba relativamente fija y para
que entiendas de lo que trata esta
gráfica
aquí tenemos moneda de tailandia
relativa al dólar estadounidense
parece ser que estaban alrededor de 25
26 en moneda tailandesa por cada dólar
estadounidense y vemos aquí que están
más o menos vinculados y veníamos
hablando de como un banco central puede
vincular moneda comprando y vendiendo
reservas de dólar estadounidense pero
luego de repente tú lo que puedes ver
aquí en 1997 hubo una devaluación de
repente tienes mucho más en moneda
tailandesa por cada dólar luego tú
puedes ver aquí comenzó a flotar el
dinero no había una vinculación directa
entre ellos dos y eso es porque
experimento la dinámica que observamos
en los vídeos pasados lo que yo quiero
hacer en este vídeo es bueno quizás tú
digas lo que qué mala onda un ataque
especulativo en la moneda un de repente
las importaciones serán más caras subida
el costo una forma de vivir para las
personas del país entonces bueno por qué
por qué es tan tan malo esto en este
vídeo yo quiero darte un ejemplo del por
qué puede ser tan tan malo que un ataque
en la moneda o una devaluación masiva en
la moneda puede llevar una crisis
bancaria entonces regresemos a inicios
de los 90s lo voy a poner aquí a
principios de los 90s lo escribo
principios de los noventas 1990 si
puedes tú ver aquí que tailandia tenía
una bastante alta tasa de interés a
corto plazo es esta línea azul de aquí
si vamos a 1992 analizamos y vemos que
la tasa de interés a corto plazo
está más o menos en el once o doce por
ciento más o menos por ahí anda y puedes
imaginar la moneda tenía una buena
vinculación con respecto al dólar las
personas podían ver que tailandia tiene
una economía saludable y los
inversionistas decían wow yo puede ir a
tailandia y obtener tasas de interés
altas y tú puedes imaginar a un banco de
tailandia diciendo bueno mira todos
ellos quieren invertir en tailandia en
lugar de yo querer pedir préstamos a
depositantes en tailandia yo puedo ir al
extranjero y pedir prestado y lo
invierto en tailandia entonces pensemos
en esto acá tenemos a eeuu y por acá
tenemos a tailandia ahora yo no he
investigado las verdaderas tasas de
interés pero supongamos que a principios
de los 90 se estaban abajo y por
simplicidad supongamos que eeuu tenía
una tasa de interés de el 7% el 7%
en tailandia digamos también por
simplicidad que no sé en el 11% entonces
tú puedes imaginar imagina que todo es
una empresa bancaria imagina que eres
una empresa bancaria te voy a dibujar
aquí en amarillo tú eres esta empresa
bancaria y tú dirías bueno porque no voy
yo a eeuu
pido dólares que están en 7% así que yo
pido prestado pido prestado dólares en
7% luego lo llevo a tailandia lo
convierto a moneda manejada en tailandia
obteniendo así 25 por cada dólar
entonces ya llegando tailandia lo presto
yo en 11% presto en 11% y de esta manera
yo estaré obteniendo alrededor de un 4%
que queda esparcido entonces 4%
esparcido y bueno cuáles son los riesgos
aquí cuál es el riesgo de pedir prestado
en un país extranjero y luego prestarlo
en tu país
bueno el verdadero riesgo está en si las
monedas están vinculadas si la moneda
extranjera está vinculada a la de tu
país
es un banco tailandés a inicios de los
90 es tu puedes ver aquí que hay un
enorme demanda de otras personas
queriendo convertir su moneda a la de
tailandia hay tanta demanda que para
mantener la vinculación el banco central
tailandés está imprimiendo dinero y
comprando dólares aquí tenemos al banco
central de tailandia juntando una enorme
reserva de dólares así si por cualquier
razón si los inversionistas deciden
retirarse el banco central aún puede
mantener la tasa de cambio fija ellos
dicen aquí hay algo estable yo puedo
mantener mi 4% dinero fácil genial pero
como sabemos no siempre es tan sencillo
algo puede pasar y kabul llevar a la
crisis entonces en 1997 eso fue
exactamente lo que pasó hubo un boom en
tailandia estaban ocurriendo muchos
préstamos pero quizás esos préstamos no
ocurrieron los mejores lugares o no en
los adecuados en particular pasaba en
bienes raíces en una forma especulativa
y los inversionistas se empezaban a
asustar así que los inversionistas
empiezan a quitar se empiezan a quitar
porque bueno se asustan entonces
empiezan a quitar
y vimos en los vídeos pasados quizás
esto pase naturalmente luego hay un
ataque especulativo quizás veas a
especuladores de divisas y digan voy a
empezar a pedir prestado tailandia luego
lo convertiré a dólares después invertir
en eeuu y teniendo la esperanza de que
esta devaluación ocurra sin saber que si
la suficiente cantidad de personas hacen
lo mismo el banco de tailandia se va a
quedar sin reservas y la razón por la
cual esto implica un gran riesgo es
porque si se queda sin reservas que va a
pasar por ejemplo qué pasará con esta
persona que pidió dólares y después los
presenta islandia aquí tú puedes ver que
hubo una devaluación masiva que el valor
de la moneda tailandesa relativa al
dólar se fue a la mitad o casi a la
mitad entonces un de repente tú pides
prestado este país dólares y ves que wow
todo está fuera de control porque su
valor ahora está al doble las cosas no
son como tú quieres que salieran
relativas a los ingresos que tú recibes
justamente aquí entonces um de repente
si tus deudas suben al doble relativo a
tu moneda a la moneda manejada en tu
país
tú debes el doble y con toda esta
situación con todo esto que ahora tú le
debes al banco el doble y si así siguen
las cosas tú probablemente lo más seguro
es que vayas a bancarrota esto está
pasando en una escala masiva está
pasando por toda tailandia y su sector
bancario no simplemente los importes
fueron afectados todo el sistema
financiero
en tailandia se colapsó